hey guys I'm back and today we're gonna
talk about what to do if you're losing
hair when you're doing keto and in a
minute fasting okay well most of the
time if you're doing intermittent
fasting in keto you're gonna get your
hair back it's gonna grow more but if it
doesn't this is what you need to look at
calories okay
if you're not consuming enough calories
if you're going on a low-calorie diet
just not consuming enough you just
somehow decided that you're gonna do
this with a small real small amount of
food and you're not going to have the
basic nutrients to feed the proteins of
the body and the nutrients that help
support the proteins that's going to
also affect the thyroid gland and you
could lose your hair so what you want to
do is we want to make sure when you
start including intermittent fasting
your three meals and then your two meals
okay and then you're at one meal that
you have enough food that has enough
nutrients in it you want to consume
nutrient-dense foods but make sure it's
bigger okay but the first nutrient you
want to make sure you have enough of is
protein if you're consuming not enough
protein that's probably why you're
losing hair so if you're doing three
houses per meal then go up to 4 to 5
ounces and see if that doesn't just
handle it ok a lot of times when people
start doing this their hunger goes away
and so they just hardly eat they just
barely eat anything and what's going to
happen is like they may start showing
signs of nutrition deficiency and they
have the situation where they're just
not hungry and you know you've watched
one of my videos where I talked about
don't eat if you're not hungry but what
I want to clarify about that is that at
some point in the day you're going to
have to consume some nutrients right and
just increase the amount of food that
you consume and make sure it had
fulfills your nutrient requirement
because the key thing is we want to make
sure we're not never doing a low calorie
diet and the definition of that is not
consuming enough calories to meet our
nutritional needs so especially if
you're doing foods that are not
nutrient-dense you're going to be in
trouble with that so
if you start showing signs of hair loss
and nail brittleness that we know and
fatigue so those are really good
indicators hair nails energy level are
really good indicators to know that
you're getting your nutrients or not
okay from your food the other thing is
that when you do go through what's
called key to adaptation and you're
adapting the fad you need more of
certain nutrients you need B vitamins
and minerals especially potassium so if
you're not consuming those extra added
supplements and you're not consuming
seven to ten cups of vegetables and
you're not consuming nutritional yeast
but your body demands more of these
nutrients to make the new cellular
machinery that could be why you're
losing your hair so add some nutritional
yeast and minerals electrolyte powder
and trace minerals which is are very
very important trace manners are
minerals that are needed in very small
amounts that help proteins form in the
body so this is a very vital thing to
help your hair nails collagen okay the
other thing I want to mention is that
your stomach acid if you have low
stomach acid and you're not able to
digest the protein that could be one
reason why it's not ending up in your
hair and the way that you would know if
you have low stomach acids is you would
have heartburn indigestion bloating and
gas okay so if you have that then you
need to increase more acid by apple
cider vinegar you can get them in
tablets or attain how to chloride or the
combination of both those two work
really really good so again we if you're
doing more protein
you know beefed up the protein no pun
intended
a good formula B would be between 0.36
grams
2.7 grams times your body weight so if
you weigh 180 pounds you would times
five point three seven and that would be
the very minimum that you would want to
consume and then you would want to go up
to 0.7 but again I'm giving you the
once's right here because
time's the Grahams are confusing
especially if you're trying to measure
the food in grams because you don't want
to calculate let's say for example you
have chicken or fish or an egg you're
not looking for the total grams of that
food you're looking for the grams of
protein in that meat or animal product
or product itself not that total grams
big confusion in other words the grams
of beef for example in protein are a lot
less than the total grams of when it
weighs because you have the fat in there
you have the water in there which is
quite a large amount of so any of the
collagen and some other things too all
right okay so I hope that helped and
thanks for watching
hey guys a lot of you already have my
book some of you don't but this new
edition called the new body type guide
is an upgrade from my last edition
called the seven principles of fat
burning it has a hundred and fifty six
images three hundred seventy eight pages
full glossary I talk about keto in a
minute fasting the body types in detail
I have a new stressed chapter I'm going
to show you exactly what to eat and a
comprehensive FAQ I put a link down
below check it out